over the past week or so the league
community has been surprised confused
and somewhat disturbed by a pick that is
taking over the meta roaming janna top
with smite now on paper this seems like
the fastest way to get yourself a ban
for hinting but in high elo it's proving
to be really really strong in fact it's
now the highest win rate champion in its
role and is exposing a flaw at the very
heart of how league of legends works
[Music]
look i know it you know it we all know
you should be subscribed to the score
esports the thing we don't know is if
you haven't done it yet
why that's what we don't know so until
we have the answers to that just
subscribe
then we don't have to worry about that
question
i'm not even sure this makes sense all
right so let me just lay out for you
just how weird this situation is for the
past 12 years janna has been a support
champion that has sat in the bot lane
saving a.d carries asses with shields
heels and tornadoes so you can imagine
everyone's surprised that she's now
appearing in the top lane not only that
she takes smite which is meant for
junglers and then she doesn't even spend
any time in the lane anyway she just
roams
she [ __ ] off honestly if i told you
weeks ago that i had a janna on my team
that played like that you'd say they
were hinting but right now smite
jannatop has the highest win rate of any
top laner in the game at
57.03
across all ranks she is technically now
the most effective way to win top lane
and she doesn't even spend any time
there i cannot stress enough how mad
this is it's being played at the highest
level of solo queue very successfully by
the likes of former lcs pro lolo
oh this guy wants me he's pissed
please get pissed
they want me bro
they're so bad
just kill them all all right my
moonstones huge value
yeah yeah keep going keep going get a
pet though
go all the way i got you i got flash all
too just go just go trust me trust me i
got you i got you
yeah there it is baby
now this whole playstyle for janna
seemed to come from the european player
happy happy 2 who had a spotlight thrown
on them by the youtube channel happy
chime noises they played over 150 jana
top games already this season with an
incredible 57
win rate in masters it is no fluke they
often start by helping their jungler
with their first buff they harass enemy
laners and keep their own teammates from
being pushed under turret they
occasionally go top for a little bit of
xp but they're soon out on the map again
making the enemy junglers life a living
hell and smiting away their camps
whenever they can they do die a lot
during their games but more often than
not the enemy nexus is the one that
falls first with the enemy team
wondering what the f just happened now
on the surface it's not that obvious why
this works so well and why it's
specifically jana that can pull this
playstyle off well firstly she's quick
very quick in the early game she uses
her 8 bonus movement speed passive to
roam quickly between lanes help shove
waves and counter the enemy jungler in
the mid to late game happy happy 2 likes
to double down on this speed by building
mobi boots and shirelias to run down
enemies in an almost comical fashion her
shield slows and knock-ups can flip any
enemy gank on its head which also has
the added bonus effect of being
incredibly tilting imagine clearing your
jungle perfectly and setting up a great
gank only to be denied by a roaming
ghana three levels lower than you never
underestimate the power of tilt janna's
kit isn't the only reason this works
though happy happy 2 and their disciples
often take spell thief's edge to get
money from poking enemy champions or
turrets in any lane the smite is also a
huge deal they often use it to steal
away the first buff the enemy jungler
does which coming from a jungler is
catastrophic and for the rest of the
game janna's team has two smites to
secure barons and dragons it's kind of
sick to be honest now all of this sounds
great but we haven't mentioned one thing
the enemy top laner while janna is off
being a mad lass on the rest of the map
the enemy top laner gets endless
uncontested waves of farm and xp as well
as gold from turret plating and most
likely the turret itself you couldn't
ask for an easier lane and yet somehow
all the golden xp they could possibly
want isn't enough to stop janna and her
team now if that sounds mental
welcome to the heart of the problem here
the gold bounty system it's a bit
complicated but it works like this if
one player has earned 300 gold more from
farming minions than the average enemy
player has they get a 50 gold bounty on
their head which grows larger if the gap
increases so very quickly the enemy top
laner gains a massive gold bounty on
their head because janna is dragging
down her team's average gold earned from
minions because she's not farming
minions sure the enemy top is getting
pretty fed off all the gold but janna is
getting her whole team ahead across the
map and eventually they're gonna group
up and kill the enemy top laner at which
point they'll cash in on that fat fat
bounty on top of that janna and her
winning team may be able to cash in on
objective bounties too such as turrets
and dragons because i'm picking janna a
champion inherently doesn't need gold to
actually function i can be 5000 gold
down on this renekton and all of a
sudden my jinx who i've just been in is
laying the whole game has seven kills my
kali mid lane has 10 kills yes their
renekt is 5000 gold ahead of us but we
still have objective bounties and you're
super super fed scale and carry now gets
even more gold injected into them
because they're able to get objective
boundaries from a position in the game
where they're actually like up on gold
it's just i have no gold and your other
sport has no gold so you're behind on
gold overall so it's really really weird
and it kind of abuses that mechanic i
think super hard and
my feeling is that people are gonna look
for other things too you know i've seen
uh the ghost roaming gragas now some
people do it with rakan there's like a
few a few versions of this and it's just
like
clearly there's a lot of problems with
top lane when the funnel strat shook up
the entire meta in 2018 wright had to
implement sweeping changes to fix the
game and return it to some semblance of
normality i wouldn't say things are as
crazy as they were back then because
unlike funnel strat we haven't seen jana
top in pro play
yeah but that doesn't mean we won't see
riot jumping to fix this very soon
because as we've already discussed this
isn't just a quirky problem with one
champion it exposes some massive flaws
at the heart of top lane and the bounty
system if you've played any league over
the past couple of years you'll know how
this system can be a huge game deciding
factor this playstyle has exposed the
cracks will riots seal them up or are we
about to see the mighty bounty system
crumble at the hands of a roaming janna
top
just like disco nunu back in the day a
roaming janitor now i'm gonna remove
this i've made that i've made the point
let's not belabor the point a lads
let's just get the [ __ ] video going
you'll know how this system is uh
[ __ ] what what is it can be a huge
game deciding factor you'll know the
bounty system is [ __ ] say it your
system can be a huge game deciding
factor you'll know how this system can
be a huge game deciding factor
for me he's done it